(Guitar)
(Singing)
Rollercoaster,
carousel.
Where the highs are heaven,
but the lows,
oh, they can be hell.
You can grab the ring,
you can ring that bell,
when the ride is over,
you can never tell.
People tell you this one thing --
will make your life complete.
So you,
you give it everything you got
and you wind up on the street.
Then one day you wake up,
and they tell you "you're a queen,"
but then you find that someone else
is pulling on the strings.
Rollercoaster,
carousel.
Where the highs are heaven,
but the lows,
oh, they can be hell.
You can grab the ring,
you can ring that bell,
when the ride is over,
you can never tell.
The one you love,
they love you --
oh yeah --
until the end of time.
But lose your edge or lose your cool,
they will drop you like a dime.
Everyone is crowding 'round
when fortune is your friend.
When your luck is running out,
you're all alone again.
Rollercoaster,
carousel.
Where the highs are heaven
but the lows,
oh, they can be hell.
You can grab the ring,
you can ring that bell,
when the ride is over
you can never tell.
Well, maybe I'm just cynical,
and all these words are lies,
but experience keeps telling me
that the cautious one is wise.
But caution makes you hesitate,
and hesitate you're lost,
so take your opportunities
and never count the cost.
Rollercoaster,
carousel.
Where the highs are heaven,
but the lows,
oh, they can be hell.
You can grab the ring,
you can ring that bell,
when the ride is over --
over, over,
you can never, ever tell.
Rollercoaster,
carousel,
rollercoaster,
yeah, yeah, yeah,
carousel.
Carousel,
carousel,
carousel.
(Applause)
Michael Pemberton.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.